We are about to visit the old town of Wakimachi
It is a street lined with old buildings that were involved in the commerce of Aizome,
which is the blue dye that was used for traditional clothes such as hakama.
That place was the largest selling point in South Japan.
Let's go to see the old town.
This is the old town of Wakimachi.
The entire street is bordered by buildings that are over 100 years old.
Many of them are shops or storehouses for Aizome.
Aizome was the typical blue dye used for clothes in Japan.
These "Udatsu" protruding walls on both ends of the house's façade are really specific to the region.
They were used to represent the success of the business [and protect against spread in case of fire].
We got the opportunity to visit one of these buildings and everything was still as it was 100 years ago.
So it makes this city very interesting because it has not changed much since the Edo era.
This is very rare in Japan.
All the Daito-ryu from Wakimachi comes from here.
It came from Hokkaido and travelled all the way down to here.
This place is the Hombu [head dojo] of Shikoku, the South of Japan.
Here is a typical house from the time, over 150 years ago.
This one is not a commercial house and therefore, it does not bear the Udatsu columns that we saw earlier.
It depends on the individual's conscience.
If one is magnanimous, then there is some consideration in the technique.
There is compassion.
So it is only down to a personal conviction?
Yes.
It depends on one's heart.
If the compassion and the spirit of Takeda Sokaku, Nakatsu Sensei, and now Chiba Sensei were all a bit different,
can we conclude that the Daito-ryu is also different?
In the end, what are we talking about?
At each period, different things happen.
People's ideas evolve and the spirit changes according to what happens at the time.
If things did not change, no one would be interested, and these things would become irrelevant today.
So if war broke again, it would be different.
But the techniques wouldn't change right?
No they wouldn't change.
It is the spirit and the way to teach that can change.
This is the topic of the next question right?
What is the relation between Buddhism and Daito-ryu?
You mention Buddhism but it could be said of any other tradition.
The question could be the same for you right?
Yes.
What I always say is: "Do it calmly" because we have to produce nervous sensitivity.
We can't just do it by our own will; it has to be done collectively.
It is an important principle.
Only then, is it Buddhism.
The Buddhist character is "Wa" [litt: harmony, peace, softening]
Does this imply that there is no deep meaning to be found?
Not at all! On the contrary, there is a lot of depth in the meaning of "Wa".
One must achieve that "Wa", like in "Hei-Wa" [peace].
It is like in the song "To have peace, be ready for war".
This is the paradox we have to face to reach that peace.
This search for peace underlies this quest [of Daito-ryu].
The meaning of the "Sho-wa" era is "to make peace shine" and the meaning of "Hei-sei" is "to become peace".
So to go back to Aikido and Aiki-jujutsu, is there a difference of essence?
Aikido has "Michi", which means a path. This idea of path means that there is a spirit in "Ai".
Aikido is connected to the path of "Ai". We can think that it is spiritual or moral.
In "Ju-jutsu", "Ju" means "gentle", "soft", "tender".
"Jutsu" is the technique [a mean, a trick, an art].
It means that we are soft and we see the other as fundamentally soft too.
So teaching and learning is "Manabu" [in-depth study, same character as "Gaku", science].
Japanese language is difficult!
There is meaning inside meaning!
It's 8 a.m.
and although we where out last night, people are already training.
They are working on the points that we saw yesterday.
And this is taking place before the actual seminar.
So on top of the 5 hours of Daito-ryu with Chiba Sensei,
we also work amongst ourselves on the details.
It sums up to a lot of training in the weekend.
Hey Guillaume, how are you?
You asked me earlier about why are we coming all the way to Shikoku from Tokyo
I think that beyond learning Daito-ryu, it is really a question of depth.
There a re a lot of Sensei in Japan, in France and elsewhere
who teach things that are correct,
and I think that everyone teaches things that are correct, or try to teach correct things.
The issue is in the depth of teaching and how far we can gow in the techniques and details.
This is what we find here, we have access to a very deep technical knowledge.
It is not easy to learn all that because there are a lot of details
and until now, I have not found anybody else here in Japan who could teach to that level of details in Aikido, in Daito-ryu, etc.
I think that this is why we come here to see Chiba Sensei and Sato Sensei because with them, we truly get to the heart of Aiki.
That makes it really interesting.
See you later!
Good morning!
Like this, on the elbow,
so that it moves like this.
This is Ni-kajo.
There, go towards his chest.
It is in this motion only that all the sense of the technique resides.
Do a throwing movement in that direction,
and from that point, over there.
It is not a lack of goodwill, it is because are sizes are different.
And consequently, are arms length are different.
His [arm's] length is about half of his height.
So how are we supposed to do it?
You have to bring him there.
Look at me, I don't move.
So do it this way.
If you do it like this, he can punch.
So do it like this instead, and then over there!
Regarding the techniques with weapons, how does it work in Daito-ryu?
The meaning of "Ki" in "Bu-Ki" is that of "tool", or "vessel" as in cookware.
Buki is the warrior's tool [the 8 direction strikes].
When one uses the 8 directions upon other people, the Buddhist term is "Katsu", "to win".
KA!
The opponent is then paralyzed.
I throw my Kokyu at him.
My spirit is throwing something.
Something is getting out of me.
Does this mean that a weapon is not something that is separate from oneself?
This is because "Bu" does not mean to "fight" but "to stop the spear".
The "Bu" character is composed of two parts,
"Hoko", the "spear", and "Tomeru", "to stop".
Therefore, "Bu" means "to put an end to the fight".
As a consequence, the sword's purpose is not for killing.
What is beyond the mastery of a tool or an art?
You can generalize and anything can then become a tool, a weapon.
The whole person can become a tool or a specialized art.
Anything can develop as such from the extensions of one's body.
Even with simple chopsticks, I can target the eyes and turn them into weapons.
This leads us to "Tachi", the long-sword.
It represents what goes "beyond"
The specialized object can take many forms. Anything will do and can be turned into a weapon.
So should we understand that in Daito-ryu, the study of weapons is not a separate curriculum in itself?
No, it is all the same thing.
When the attack comes, the hand is here to protect.
This can serve as well.
It means that anything can do to protect yourself.
This is why all of that is included in the scrolls over there.
This is why if I give an atemi like this,
in Daito-ryu, we can use Ura-Ken like this...
The hand position that we studied last time was like this...
I asked "Which one is omote?"
But I got no answer.
Really?
Yes, so I said: "What is Ura then?" But I got no answer either.
But usually we see that omote...
What is written here means "Gauntlet", the back of the hand, its shell.
"Kou" is the back of the hand and the palm is "Sho".
So there is no difference between Omote and Ura.
Omote is the back of the hand and Ura is the palm.
We can show Ura like this.
If we do that it means "no, not that".
So Omote and Ura are one and same thing. It is the same for the techniques.
It is like two sides of a coin isn't it?
There is a head and a tail but it is still the same coin.
And it is the same for the techniques.
It means that if we are using the back of the hand, we are using a weapon.
But when we use the palm, it is to say "stop".
Even if you slap someone with the palm, it is not a big deal.
We even do it to ourselves like that!
We do like this to ourselves or to others.
You find this in Sumo too during the "Tsuppari" techniques.
But can't say these are weapons too?
Yes, this is why I said that the two aspects were the same thing.
Omote becomes a weapons and Ura can become one too.
Look, when we wave our hand to say no, both sides are in action, we don't only wave the palm.
This is what it means.
What are the technical roots of weapons in Daito-ryu?
[Shingen Jiki] Shinkage [ryu]
Shinkage-ryu...
Regarding the Shinkage influence, the source comes from Aizu.
There are also a lot of techniques from Ono-ha Itto-ryu.
But there is Shinkage also.
Did you practice Shinkage-ryu?
No, I mainly did Itto-ryu.
So there is influence from these two schools.